what would you say would be alex's
legacy i would say
he made being smart cool
he made being an intellectual look like
a sport
and you rooted for these people that
were like division one and professional
athletes yes
and he made it cool because he was cool
and he was that smart
there's this beautiful clip of a man
talking about actually learning
english because of alex you see the
emotion from him
any family members back home cheering
you on
you know here's a true story man i grew
up i learned english because of you
and so my grandfather who who raised me
i'm going to get tears right now he
we i used to sit on his lap and watch
you every day so
it's a pretty special moment for me man
tell me about that story in that day
what's amazing is how often that has
happened to him he has touched so many
lives and he's been such a fixture
uh for so long but that day we had a
contestant he was from india had an
amazing
backstory and he said that
ultimately he learned english and
his perfect diction he attributed to
alex trebek
and it moved alex i mean it really you
know not he was pretty steady on that
stage
and it it took him back he fought this
cancer battle and he fought it publicly
too
and he and he really didn't want people
to feel sorry for him
what was that like to watch that it was
really hard to
understand what he was doing because he
was so
public about it but then did not want
people feeling sorry for him didn't want
you to look at him that way
when he walked onto that stage he was
still the man
and he was still the man until you he
told you he wasn't the man
so it was it was very tough to watch him
in pain because we all knew what was
going on
it was beyond impressive
watching him then pick himself up and
deliver the show at the highest level
what will be the moment that you will
always remember about alex
i was in his office at his house
and we were having a conversation about
the future of the show and
writing and includes and gene his wife
walked in
and kevin it was like the rest of the
world stopped
he said oh genie come on in you have to
meet mike
and and and you he loved her so much
it was visible in the room and you would
think it would be a jeopardy moment or
something like that it was the
wow this guy is the real deal he's
a great family man and a great
broadcaster
and that is what makes him special you
know
look every show eventually has gone in
alex talked about who he might want one
day to replace him
and he mentioned some very interesting
people did he say anything about
future plans for the show he never
mentioned names to us
he really
wanted to be the host of the show while
he was the host of the show so
we didn't say hey what about this person
or what about that person and we haven't
it was his show until he told us he was
gonna retire
and amazingly he never did and i think
that's a blessing
uh he did talk about what it would take
to be a good jeopardy host
um typical alex he was self-deprecating
said it's not that hard
let me tell you that is maybe the
hardest show on television
to host 61 clues in 22 minutes
accents pronunciations scoring
calling on people ruling on the answers
so he he he talked a lot about that it
needs to be someone
that the audience will respect that's
believable in the role
has credibility um and and that's
and and that's who he was and he was so
smart that you
you bought it because you knew he knew
the answer too
is there at least a list that you are
that you all will think through once the
morning period is over we have
thoughts and a plan but
one of the things that we have done is
we have not actively pursued people
because we still had our guy and now we
don't
and now we will eventually you know
in a couple weeks have start having
those conversations because we owe it to
alex
to keep the show going that's the only
thing that will propel us to be honest
um and that's when we'll start to to
really
uh talk to people and and and see who
can do this it's going to take uh
someone with an amazing skill set will
the show come back
in the new year yes absolutely
that is the one thing he made us promise
that this
great show was not done he did not
want to be bigger than the show fought
that his whole time
he said it's the show it's the clues
it's the contestants
um obviously we all feel
that he was an incredibly huge part of
that but that was his take so
we will be back um we're in mourning now
uh as a group as you can imagine but uh
we
we will be back and um and we'll honor
his legacy by
producing more great shows how will you
pay tribute to alex
we recorded a message that i delivered
on the jeopardy set just explaining to
everyone that these are his final 35
shows
um and uh and that
he wanted us to air them so so to enjoy
them
and enjoy him at the top of his game
we'll honor him
every show this season obviously will be
um dedicated to him and and really i
think the best thing that we can do
to honor him is to come back and make
great jeopardy shows how hard was it to
deliver that message to that crew which
i'm sure is a close-knit crew and those
are people who had worked with him for
so many years
it's the toughest thing i've ever done
and uh
you can tell i'm i'm fighting back tears
everyone
is around on the on the crew everyone is
in tears
um but we wanted to do the right thing
for him and that's what we're
that's what we're going to do and that's
kind of that's what drove us